jean pierre pernaut est sans conteste le
journaliste préféré des français
présent depuis plus de 30 ans à la tête
du journal de 13 heures l'un des plus
regardés de france chaque jour mesdames
et messieurs bonjour les records
d'audience qui s'accumulent chaque année
depuis des décennies une personnalité
aimé des français est devenu l'un des
visages de l'info en france grâce à son
ton unique et son attrait pour les
métiers et les villages trop souvent
oublié une célébrité si précieuse pour
tf1 que la chaîne a même décidé de le
faire remplacer durant l'épidémie de
coronavirus pour tenter à tout prix de
le protéger de cette infection ravageuse
lui qui a fait face récemment à des
ennuis de santé importants et jean
pierre pernaut c'est aussi un discours
sans langue de bois s'il ne cherche
jamais la polémique
le journaliste m en revanche dire ce
qu'il pense sans détour et une fois de
plus même en confinement c'est ce qu'il
a fait après avoir critiqué le maintien
du premier tour des élections
municipales il ya quelques semaines
c'est une nouvelle fois contre le
gouvernement que le présentateur du 13
heures s'est exprimée cette fois ci il a
ironisé au sujet des déclarations du
ministre de l'éducation jean michel
blanquer requis expliqué que les écoles
pour aurait ouvrir le 4 mai prochain
pour jean pierre pernaut il s'agirait
d'un mensonge la reprise le quatre-mâts
personne n'y croirait dans cinq semaines
à venir et sera toujours là qu'on se le
dise jean pierre pernaut n'est pas un
journaliste comme les autres alors coup
de gueule de jean pierre pernaut contre
le gouvernement choqués ou pas choquer
alors c'est vrai que jean-pierre il
n'hésite pas à dire ce qu'ils pensent
même à l'antenne regarder lundi dernier
dans son dernier jt avant qu'ils
décident de voilà de rester chez lui et
il a bien raison il avait qualifié d'
inconscient les français qui se baladait
dans les rues et les parcs et ça il a
bien raison je vous dis restez chez vous
regardez ce petit extra après avoir
parlé de psychose au début de l'épidémie
maintenant pas plus de psychose car y
ait une véritable menace
mais il y avait encore hier on l'a vu au
journal d inconscient il n'y a pas
d'autre mot dans les rues dans les parcs
mais beaucoup de français s'inquiètent
quand même dans les pharmacies qui reste
ouverte malgré le stade iii bat toujours
pas de masque non plus peu de gel met
beaucoup de monde
alors ça déjà jean pierre c'est vrai que
tu avais vu tout de suite le truc un
tamis qu'il fallait rester chez soi ça
c'est vrai que tu es un des seuls à dire
des choses comme ça dans ton dans son jt
alors je vais rectifier quand même un
petit peu ce que vous avez dit dans le
reportage qui était très sympa ce sont
pas des coups de gueule ce sont des
remarques de bon sens je n'ai pas à m'en
prendre à qui que ce soit ni au
gouvernement ni à personne
je remarque par exemple que ya pas de
masque il n'y a pas de gel c'est une
c'est un constat je remarque qu'on nous
dit avec thé chez nous puis d'aller
voter quand même c'est un constat je ne
vivais pas de coup de gueule à vic et
moi je suis journaliste je dois me poser
des questions c'est notre métier je dois
me poser des questions ce n'est posera
plus tard pourquoi n'y avait pas de
masque pourquoi on nous dit que c'est
inutile alors que c b à ba de la
protection dans le monde entier tout le
monde en porte
en france on nous dit que c'est inutile
parce qu'il ya pas de stock mais c'est
vrai qu'il faut les réserver au
personnel médical
je pense à tous les médecins infirmières
qui bossent toute dépendance moment ils
ont besoin de ces masques on a besoin de
ces masques dans les maisons de retraite
et ses incroyables dans un pays comme le
nôtre n'est pas eu les stocks on est con
et liquider les stocks de madame
bachelot qui avait eu raison d'en
constituer et je salue rose livre parce
que voilà alors il a été tellement
critiqué mais bon mais c'est pas des
coups de gueule que je clique ce sont
des remarques de bon sens que tout le
monde
tout le monde a donc voilà c'est ça tu
avais dit le mot métier de journaliste
tu avais dit jean-pierre on n'a pas été
assez alarmiste dès le début les jeunes
notamment ne se sont pas rendus compte
que c'était grave ce week end je ne suis
pas allé voter
il était hors de question que je sors de
chez moi et prenne le moindre risque
moi je regarde tout simplement ce qui se
passe en italie les courbes d'évolution
de la maladie en deuil
en france les courbes était strictement
parallèle avec dix jours de retard au
nombre de morts quand envers des courbes
aujourd'hui on a aux jours de retard
j'espère j'espère je souhaite que les
mesures de confinement prises en france
seront respectés pour qu'on n'arrive pas
au stade de l'italie mais je regarde
tout ça c'est évident que c'est même
menacé d'une lourde le 3 février
des scientifiques français qui en toile
peuvent amap lui disait qu'il y avait
peu de chances pour que la maladie
arrive en france pour que l'épidémie
arrive en france le 20 janvier le même
but vint disait qu'il avait absolument
aucun risque que pour l'épidémie avait
en france pendant ce temps là pour se
préparer
je pense que c'est à ce moment là mais
il faut pas polémiquer il faut soutenir
les m
pour rester chez soi et pas voulu voilà
alors tu avais dit être apte à critiquer
de la gestion des masques voilà après un
sujet sur la situation en italie tu t'ai
demandé pourquoi nous on ne portait pas
de masque regarde ce qu'est le 11 mars
donc à beaucoup beaucoup d'italiens avec
des masques de protection c'est le b à
ba de la protection comme en chine on
met des masques en france on nous dit
toujours que c'est inutile
peut-être parce qu'on en a pas alors
jean-pierre c'est vrai que ça aussi
c'est un coup de gueule qui a été
énormément repris parce que tu ta
conscience que tu as ta parole mine de
rien elle touche près de toul et francis
d'ici jean-pierre le dit c'est que c'est
que c'est vrai c'est qu'il ya un souci
mais c'est par un coup de mieux que j'ai
dit peut-être parce qu'on en a pas il
paraît qu'il ya des stocks mais dans les
maisons de retraite on en manque les
infirmières libérales non pas pour aller
soigner des personnes âgées pour se
protéger elle-même et pour protéger les
personnes âgées qu'elles vont soigner et
puis c'est vrai que nous at il envie je
crois qu'il ya eu fin du mois de
décembre une campagne d'une salle la
santé nord qu'au moment de mettre des
masques pour nous protéger de la grippe
pouvait retrouver ce truc là et puis
également après un but ça sert à rien
c'est vrai qu'il ya un manque de basses
qu'il faut les réserver aux personnels
soignants c'était vivant mais on ne peut
pas dire en même temps que ça sert à
rien un studio alors rené toi tu tues tu
comprends le voilà ce qu'en jean-pierre
que jean-pierre dise les choses comme ça
voilà c'est normal qu'ils aient qui les
dissuade qu'est ce t'en penses
ouais mais tu sais syrie y'a pas que
j'obtiens le dis moi ça fait des depuis
le mois de février je le dis la dernière
vidéo que tu me dis qu on a bien rigolé
alors quelle est ta rigolote à l'afrique
à main trois cent mille vies alors on
sait arrêtons de croix concertée qui met
tout le monde il faut il y aller
reims est de nouveau attendu en parle
aux gens que tu peux prendre d'accord
moi il n'est pas question de vieira
demain j'irai d'aller dans l'édification
de ce fonds n'a virus ou des thérapies à
mettre en place
j'ai comparé à ça le sol ce que je dis
moi qui tu habites world devant tout le
talent de tous les nôtres l'histoire fut
rade
tu as vu mon nom et ma mois le lendemain
de match sur un minuscule et en dehors
et là je suis confié financier n'est que
jamais à vélo c'est bien moi et pourtant
je cite aussi des aidants la vidéo d'un
tabatière un jeu dans le jeu les tracts
de tous c'est parce que [ __ ] il faut
qu'ils ratissent depuis le monde
je sais ce que c'est ce qu'ont à dire
finie je supporte pas d'accord calme-toi
calme toi mon run est calme toi jean
pierre pernaut nous avait toujours dans
une interview au parisien ce week end
j'en vois tous ceux qui ont dit que ça
n'arriverait pas en france on a perdu du
temps jusqu'à la première intervention
des manuels macron jeudi dernier on nous
demandait de nous laver les mains puis
de ne plus rendre visite aux personnes
âgées en maison de retraite mais il n'y
avait pas de contrôles aux frontières
dans les aéroports je m'en suis étonné à
l'antenne en faisant quelques remarques
c'est tout alors je ne sais pas qui a
raison dans cette affaire on le verra
après coup je me souviens très bien en
tâches qu'on allait faire voici ses
plans de l'absence totale de contrôle à
roissy contrôle de température et c'est
un peu partout dans le monde il y avait
ce type d contrôler ce que la hausse
avait raison aujourd'hui savoir très
bien jean-pierre ça te montre sa demande
t-on jt ou pas mais non parce que tf1 a
eu la gentillesse de m'installer à mini
studio à la maison donc tous les jours
j'ai ma petite intervention au trésor je
suis surveillé par ma femme maquillée
par ma fille éclairé par mon fils
voilà on fait la tirrenia je suis avec
vous parce que c'est génial vont souvent
se dit tiens il paraît que les gens le
droit de reina c'est pas vrai on nous a
jamais interdit d'aller chez toi je me
souviens que de la cnec cgt 35 ans avec
un gâteau sur ton plateau avec des
chroniqueurs que j'adore et puis non pas
que l'on mangeait pas intérêt à dire du
mal de nous n'a pas ce que dit rassuré
hier matin à bord mais bon c'est ça ça
va mieux là ça y est il ya plus tf1 et
canal là on est c'est fini on dépend des
dans autre chose à mon chéri vraiment
merci en tout cas jean pierre jean
pierre on a
jacques legros tu lui donnes étaient
petits conseils tu l'appelles ou pas
jacques me replace depuis 21 ans donc
jacques eux s'occupent tout seul de
l'actualité avec la rédactrice en chef
caroline henry et lionel charpentier
mais moi je suis pour ma petite partie
de fin qui s'appelle 13 heures à la
maison qu'on va un petit peu grossir la
semaine prochaine avec des témoignages
de français qui nous racontent comment
ils vivent confinement apparemment on
est parti donc pour six mêmes donc la
rentrée des classes le 5 mai non là on
est confiné pour six semaines a dit va
confirmer sans doute le président de
l'apic d'un journée mais a dit le
conseil scientifique qui l'entourent six
semaines ça nous amène aux 5 6 mai donc
je m'étonnerai que le jour où on va
pouvoir sortir pour la première fois les
enfants vont retourner à l'école
ce sera un petit peu plus peur donc et
xavier remarque de bon je fais à
l'antenne si jamais des règlements de
comptes jamais des critiques parce que
j'aimerais pas être à la place du
gouvernement je peux vous le dire vivre
une crise pareille c'est la pièce
rendent du siècle même peut-être des
deux derniers siècles en temps de paix
une crise en plantes peu de ce type en a
jamais vécu ça en france et
économiquement ça va être une une
catastrophe gigantesque donc je prie
pour que le gouvernement et bosse bien
et je ne l'écris zim pas fait des
remarques de bon sens quand les choses
sont pas compréhensibles
nathalie ma chérie comment savait ce
qu'on te manque avec grave pour toi t'es
content valérie khem petit rage de dents
elle reviendra demain et et natalité
content que tu avec jean-pierre toi et
tu vas plus laisser retourner au jt un
tu vas leader de la soeur la maison
maintenant
ces pratiques de devoirs à la maison je
le surveillais c'est cool mais
t'inquiète apal surveiller des agents
péri jan perry dévoile à toutes ses
dents père y est comme ça ça bouge pas
ça et à toutes jambes hier je te le dis
tu es très de maquiller avant de vous
quitter je sais pas quoi faire ressortez
stx comme moi ce pays vers les autres
partis c'était un immense bonheur
voilà ce soit revue à 1 970
jova et eric merci jean mayer merci à
tous les jours chez vous aux alentours
de 13h30 à moi là sur tf1 merci nathalie
merci jean pierre t'embrasse ta fille
aussi qui est à maquilleuse je veux lui
dire en ma défaveur on est des trésors
salue la famille pernaut salue les
cherry et on dirait des gros bisous